bonjour curieuses et curieux vous avez
sûrement déjà été confronté à un
problème mathématique sans le savoir
la galère de l'emballage impossible de
couvrir parfaitement une sphère avec une
feuille de papier plus anniversaire
pourtant dans la nature beaucoup de
plantes ont des feuilles plane qui
grandissent sous forme de boules et bien
des chercheurs de paris ont trouvé
comment imiter la nature et des formes
et un objet plaint que les feuilles de
chou en grandissant les matériaux
inventé par l'équipe de chercheurs de
paris se déforme
mais il ne se déforme pas n'importe
comment l'idée au coeur de leur
recherche c'est d'être capable de
programmer la déformation
c'est à dire de construire des matériaux
qui passe de façon contrôlée d'une forme
initiale connu à une forme finale elle
aussi connu à l'image des algues vertes
unicellulaires du genre assez tabou
l'aria les chercheurs ont créé des
surfaces qui contiennent un réseau de
petits tubes de kano ces surfaces sont
en élastomère un genre de caoutchouc
très élastique et lorsqu on injecte de
l'air sous pression dans les canaux
l'élastomère se déforme ces matériaux
peuvent alors s'adapter à une forme
comme la feuille de chou s'adapte à la
croissance du coeur de la plante et ils
ont trouvé un joli nom pour leur
invention matériaux barreau morphée
barreau morphée non barre haut avec un
haut c'est la pression et morph la forme
donc qui se forme avec la pression l'air
pousse sur les parois ce qui augmente la
taille des canaux et plus précisément
c'est leur diamètre qui augmente parce
que dans la longueur les tubes ne
grandissent pas ainsi on peut savoir
exactement dans quelle direction l'objet
va se déformer mais aussi de combien il
va se déformer en fonction de la densité
des canaux sur la surface de leur
orientation et de la pression qu'on y
injecte les chercheurs montrent que pour
n'importe quelle forme en 3d ils peuvent
calculer comment disposer les canaux sur
une surface plane
pour que une fois ces canaux rempli
d'air la surface prennent la forme
voulue habile et à partir de là
évidemment les chercheurs ont inventé et
tester toutes sortes d'objets en variant
les formes l' architecture des canaux et
les types d'élastomère
balèze bienvenue dans les tutos de
léontine aujourd'hui on va apprendre à
faire un bar aux morts chez soi pour
cela il vous faut une plaque de verre
deux gobelets dans lesquels vous allez
préparer un élastomère de silicone le
même matériau qu'utilisent les dentistes
pour faire les empreintes de danse
couler l'élastomère dans le moule du
réseau de canaux que vous aurez
préalablement imprimé en 3d est allé
également une fine couche de la sto mère
qui servira de couvercle à vos canaux au
bout de vingt minutes
démouler délicatement le réseau de
canaux étalez une couche d'élastomère
pour faire à guéret le couvercle et
mettez en contact les deux parties de
votre objet qui voit là un bel objet bas
aux morts que vous pourrez gonflé et
dégonfler un autre qui juge ces objets
en matériaux barreau mort relève tous
les défis pour la première fois les
chercheurs obtiennent des objets qui se
déforment rapidement de façon totalement
reverso mais surtout des objets qui
peuvent prendre des formes très complexe
puisque on peut programmer des
déformations suivant plusieurs
directions et en plus certains peuvent
adopter deux formes différentes selon la
pression envoyés dans les tubes
[Musique]
cette recherche pourrait avoir de
nombreuses applications notamment en
médecine et les chercheurs ont
d'ailleurs déposé un brevet on pourrait
imaginer par exemple des robots
chirurgicaux souple qui s'introduisent à
travers une toute petite incision pour
opérer ou manipulés délicatement les
organes ou encore des prothèses qui
serait réglable et adaptée aux patients
et aussi pourquoi pas des structures à
déployer dans l'espace et il n'y a qu'un
pas pour que ces barreaux morse
deviennent des matériaux souples
populaire qui suivent la femme à la tête
de chou et n'oubliez pas de vous abonner
et allez faire un tour sur notre compte
instagram pour voir les coulisses